>> BOYD: So, my name is Ryan Boyd. I'm a developer
advocate at Google, working on Google Apps
and the Apps Marketplace. I hope you're all
having a really great day today and learning
a lot of things. I'm here with Marcos from
Just Digital, he is going to be presenting
a little bit of their solution using the Google
Apps APIs along with me. So, let's get started.
Here's the agenda. It's very wide. We're planning
on talking about a lot of different things
with regards to Google Apps, a lot of the
different APIs. It's going to be a broad overview
of the APIs and the capabilities of Google
Apps. It's not going to dive in super detail
on any of these. You could probably figure
that out from title, and the session abstract,
but if not, I'm not going to feel bad if you
guys decide to go to another session, if you're
already deeply familiar with these APIs. So
Google Apps, Google Apps is tools for today's
user. So, think of a lot of the consumer applications
that you're used to using on a regular basis.
Gmail, Calendar, Docs, Google Talk, all these
different types of applications are package
dub, and made available for businesses, and
adding a few of the features that businesses
need. At Google Apps, it is all based off
of the web. The web is the enterprise platform.
Technology is like HTML5, and JavaScript,
and CSS allow us to build a highly interactive
web applications that you can't tell the difference
from them versus a desktop application. Gmail
was one of the first applications that used
a lot of Ajax Technology, and it progressed
forward from there, so you have live document
editing collaboration that works really well.
Google Apps has lots of customers, and it's
growing very quickly. There are 30 million
active users of Google Apps with three million
businesses over 3,000 new businesses who are
signing up every single day, and these customers
are of all different types of businesses.
There are small businesses, they are the mom
and pop shops, or the small retail stores
going all the way through major enterprises,
and governments, and educational institutions.
So, we have the Apps from Google. We have
these communication, and collaboration Apps
that Google has, but how does this hook into
the--together with the things that you guys
built? Well, in addition to the Apps from
Google, back in March, we launched the Apps
Marketplace. The Apps Marketplace is basically
a store for you to discover and purchase web
applications that are well integrated with
Google Apps. And for you as developers, it's
an opportunity for you to sell applications
which are integrated, and it can have a lot
of the same types of integrations that the
other applications in the Google Apps suite
have. We also provide points for you to hook
in to Google Apps from custom applications.
We have platform services with App Engine
and APIs that allow you to build custom applications
and sell them to customers. And all of these
is on top of the same administration layer,
same users, same security model, and all that
you're comfortable with, with Google Apps.
Now, one of the types of APIs that Google
gives you for integrating with Google Apps
are the data APIs, and here is a brief overview
of the data APIs. They basically allow you
to hook in to the user's data, or the company's
data across the web. They are authorized using
a protocol code called OAuth. We're not going
to dive in too deeply into OAuth during this
session, but we will talk about that later
on if you guys attend my talk. I think it's
two sessions from now. But OAuth allows you
to get secure access to a user's data like
Calendar, like docs, et cetera. The data APIs
are based off of the Atom Publishing Protocol.
It's an HTTP based protocol, it uses something
called REST, or Representational State Transfer.
Basically allows you to pull objects back
and forth from the servers, and it's all based
off the Atom data format. You're probably
already familiar with Atom from the days of
dealing with blog feeds. Atom--the Atom format
describes some basic syntax that's required,
and it's highly extensible, and that's why
we've chosen to use it to build APIs for things
like Google Calendar. Now, there are two different
types of OAuth. I just want you to be familiar
with this. So about the most detail in getting
in with OAuth in this presentation, but basically
we have Three-Legged OAuth where the individual
user is the resource owner. So, when I say
resource owner, I mean like, you have your
own personal Google Calendar, you're an individual
user, you have the rights to grant access
to that calendar. There's another type of
OAuth called 2-legged OAuth, and what's that--what
that's used for is when you have a resource
that's owned by a company for them to be able
to grant an application, access to that resource
for every user within the company. So the
Three-Legged OAuth--method of OAuth is basically
a web redirect flow where the individual user
approves it, while the 2-legged OAuth is basically,
an administrator goes in, and gives an application
access to the data. There are libraries to
access all the different data APIs, so the
libraries that have variety of different languages
and these libraries implement some of the
most common functionality. Not all the libraries
implement everything, but they do implement
most--some of the most common functionality
so that you can access without understanding
the raw protocol. So there's been some recent
developments in the Google Data APIs, and
I want to talk about a couple of those here.
These are in the protocol layer of the Google
Data APIs, partial response is one of those.
So if you're developing a mobile application
that needs access to a user's Google Calendar
data, and you only need the title of an event,
and maybe the time of an event, you can request
just that information, whereas previously,
you had to request all of the information
that--about the event including the attendees,
where it was taking place, and that sort of
thing. Similarly, we've recently launched
partial updates for Google Calendar and we'll
be rolling these features out to other APIs
too, and partial updates allow you to just
patch a certain set of data. And we're going
to show an example here shortly, but basically
you can take a calendar event and just update
the title, and not pass the rest of the data,
it makes it so much more efficient to interact
with the APIs. And then we've also recently
announced the JSON protocol called JSON-C
or compact JSON, and basically gives you a
lot better JSON format for our APIs. We previously
had a JSON format that was based in large
part of--on Atom, it actually had all the
XML namespaces in JSON rather ugly. You probably
didn't like developing against it, if you're
familiar with it at all. The JSON-C format
is much more compact and more friendly for
application developers. So, speaking of applications
and Application APIs, these are all the different
types of applications that are part of the
Google Apps Suite and all of these applications
have APIs that allow you to interact with
them on behalf of the user. I'm going to give
you one example here with Google Calendar.
Google Calendar allows you to manipulate calendars
themselves. You can create, retrieve, update,
and delete calendars and you can also do the
same thing with Events and Access Control
List. You can manage what the access is to
the various calendars. And you'll notice this
create, retrieve, update, and delete, for
those of you who aren't familiar with the
term CRUD, it's basically using the common
HTTP verbs that you see on the right-hand
side there to manipulate and retrieve resources.
So, let's show what that looks like. Here
is the Atom XML for creating a calendar event.
The XML is mostly Atom here. You can see the
Atom title, which says, "Tennis with Beth,"
the Atom content, "Meet for a quick lesson."
But then you also see some areas where Google
has extended the XML and added elements in
its own namespace. These GD where, GD when,
those are very specific to Google Calendar
and describe where the event is taking place
and when the event is taking place. After
you create XML that looks like this, you can
then post it to Google Calendar at a URL like
that--I'm missing the authorization header
here, like I said, I'm not diving deep into
how that works, but when you take this content
and you post it to Google, you'll actually
get a 201 created response code knowing it
was successful or hopefully get the 201 created
response code. If you made a mistake, you'll
get a response code in the range of 400s,
et cetera. Here's an example of the partial
update feature, which I mentioned is--it's
a new feature for the Google Data APIs and
this is showing how you can patch an entry.
So let's say, the event previously was for,
"Tennis with Beth." Let's say that Beth wanted
to invite her friend Kate to play tennis as
well, she might update the title of the event
to say, "Tennis with Beth and Kate." Now,
previously to--before this partial update
protocol existed, every application would
either have to then retrieve the full entry,
modify the title, and send the full entry
back or it would have to actually store a
copy of the full entry including all the bits
of other metadata that they didn't care about.
Well, with partial update it can actually
say, using that GD Fields attribute, up here,
it can say, "I'm just modifying the title."
So, the server will go around and delete the
title from the entry, and then add the title
back in using the element that's provided
here. So, this may not look like Atom or XML.
I'm including Gmail in our list of data APIs
because it's another application that you're--you
can have access to, and Gmail is something
special here. Gmail does have an Atom based
feed. It's a read-only feed to access the
user's inbox but mail has a lot--has common
protocols that have existed for a while now.
IMAP is one of those protocols. So what Google
has done and we released earlier this year
is OAuth Authorized IMAP access, because you
don't want to give every application access
to your username and password just because
that application needs access to your mail.
You can just give it access to your mail using
OAuth and it basically creates an API out
of the IMAP standard that's existed for a
while now. And similarly we've done the same
thing with sending email by SMTP. Now, in
addition to the Application APIs for accessing
the user's data in manipulating things like
their calendars and their contacts, we also
had a series of Management APIs. There are
many different integration points for the
Management APIs; there's the Provisioning
API, this is perhaps one of the most common
APIs. It allows you to create and delete users
and things like that--we also have a Calendar
Resources API. So, if you have a bunch of
resources in your organization, things like
conference rooms or projectors or maybe even
special tools that your employees use for
their work. You can manage them as Calendar
Resources, so that when you add--when you
create a calendar event, the employees can
actually add those resources and schedule
them along with the event. There is the Email
Migration API, which allows you to push email
into Google Apps; there's an Email Settings
API, which I might show you an example of
shortly, basically allowing you to manipulate
all the settings that you use to accessing
in Gmail, a Reporting API and an Audit API.
All the different types of enterprise--these
sort of APIs that you would expect to be able
to manipulate data on behalf of an organization.
So, I'll show you one example. This is the
Email Settings API. So let's say that you
have a bunch of users who are contractors
that are actually working for other companies
on a regular basis. And you're storing that
information in, say, your HR system and you
want to update the user-signature in their
mail to let the people they're sending email
to, know who they're currently working for.
So you can actually do that with the API.
Here's an example. So Liz is a contractor,
she's working in the accounts management at
a particular company. Their HR system can
automatically update and say, "Hey. She's
working in the accounts management. Here's
her phone number." You could do similar things
with promotions and all, if the user's title
changes; automatically update the signature
in their email. Oh, and this was actually
using one of our client libraries. This is
using the Python Client Library. It's kind
of funny. I actually thought this was using
the Java Client Library, when I was reviewing
the slides at one point because it looks very
similar but there's no semi-colon so it's
definitely Python. All right. Authentication
and Users. So now we've talked about the different
APIs that you can access the different management
functionality. You're probably wondering how
you deal with authentication. If you work
with customers that are migrating to Google
Apps or customers that, you know, have existing
systems like Microsoft Exchange, et cetera,
they probably have already an existing account
system in their network. So they have something
like an active directory server, an LDAP server
or Kerberos in their network and they want
to be able to reuse those accounts when they're
using Google Apps. It's totally possible.
We'll talk about how that's done. They also
likely have Cloud Apps. They have applications
like an online payroll application and they
don't want to have users need to create new
user names and passwords for accessing those
Cloud Apps. So they want those Cloud applications
to use the Google Apps accounts, so these
can all work together and let's show you how.
First of all, the accounts must actually exist
in Google Apps but the passwords don't need
to. So, how do we get the accounts there?
So, given on premise system and you want to
create those accounts inside Google Apps,
you can use those Management APIs. There are
also tools available. Google has a directory
sync feature and Marcus' company Just Digital
has some tools for handling user accounts.
So there are a lot of things you can do if
you don't want to use the Management APIs,
but the Management APIs can sit underneath,
in particular the Provisioning API can create
those accounts, and Marcus will show you some
examples of that. For the passwords though,
you can have your passwords either migrated
with it so every time the user changes their
password in your active directory or LDAP
server or Kerberos environment, you can actually
synchronize those to Google Apps, but you
don't have to. You can use a technology called
SAML which allows you as a company to have
your own login page. And for your login page,
when a user goes to login to Google Apps,
Google will redirect the user to this login
page that you host as a company. Now you can
host this company either publicly or--sorry,
host this login page either publicly or behind
a firewall. But basically, it gives the ability
for you to authenticate the user as a Google
Apps customer and then assert the identity
of that user to Google Apps. You're telling
Google, "Hey, I know that this is my user,
John at my company, please log him in," and
Google will log him in. So you may wonder,
I talked about third party apps, these Cloud
applications that are out there. How do they
authenticate Google Apps users? Well, they're
not going to want to actually integrate with
every companies behind the firewall system
using something like SAML, but what they can
do is use OpenID as a standard to authenticate
their users. Google Apps users can then sign
in with their existing account simply by clicking
a button at the bottom that indicates that
they have a Gmail account and basically the
user goes to login. The App will redirect
to Google Apps and then the Apps trust Google
to assert the identity. This works very much
in the same way as SAML, except in a little
bit different direction. Even if Google Apps
doesn't know how to authenticate the user
on an OpenID request, it will actually redirect
over to the SAML provider and handle all of
that for you. So now, Marcus, if you come
up and talk about your company a little bit.
>> FARIAS: [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> BOYD: Thank you, Marcos. So, I want to
talk a little bit about hosting your application.
So, you can host your App anywhere. So you
can host your App on your on your servers,
in the Cloud, on your desktops, basically
anywhere that you want to host your application.
You can do that and integrate with Google
Apps. You can integrate with Google Apps as
a custom application or you can launch on
the Apps Marketplace, which I do have another
session on later talking about the Apps Marketplace
specifically, but it does not matter where
you host. These APIs are open and accessible
from any location. However--I--you know, I
wouldn't be a Googler if I didn't talk a little
bit about App Engine. You can host your application
on App Engine as well. App Engine has been
around for a bit now and provides a way for
you to build, maintain, and scale applications,
running either in Java or in Python. And we
recently--in--at Google I/O, this year launched
App Engine for business or announced App Engine
for business. This basically adds a lot of
the enterprise tools to App Engine that businesses
need. So OAuth administration aupport SLAs.
SQL is the one of the primary things here,
a lot of people have been asking for SQL,
and basically, the pricing model that we're
looking at right now for this is $8.00 per
user per month per application, so, this is
obviously intended for internal applications,
not yet for High SV use or SaaS App developers
who are selling their applications. But we
are looking at the possibility of doing a
similar sort of App Engine for business for
those markets as well. So, in addition to
hosting your full pledged application, Google
Apps also has a scripting environment, Google
Apps Script, which it allows you to run your
code in the Cloud as Server-side JavaScript.
So, JavaScript that actually sits and runs
on Google servers, you're not familiar with
that usually with JavaScript, but Apps Script
is actually really powerful. This example
here is showing how I oftentimes send emails
to developers if I have a list of their email
addresses in a spreadsheet, I can actually
add a UI element to Google Spreadsheets, called
Mail Merge you see at the bottom right here.
And when I click on that element, it actually
uses Google services to send emails to each
of those users, all configured with this Server-side
JavaScript. We also, in addition to allowing
your application to access the Google Apps
data that's hosted in the Cloud, we allow
applications hosting the Cloud to access your
unpremised systems as well. This is done using
the Secured Data Connector, basically, it
creates a tunnel from your application to
your unpremised systems. So, you can access
your CRM or ERP data, and this is what that
might actually look like. So, this is a Google
Spreadsheet, the Secured Data Connector is
accessible from App Script, and accessible
from App Engine, and it can actually retrieve
a lot of data from your internal systems.
So, you can see this invoice has data from
the CRM App, from the product catalog, from
the ERP system. A lot of different bits of
data that are hooked together and integrated
into the spreadsheet. Gadgets are one of the
last things that we're going to talk about
today as ways that you can integrate with
Google Apps, and this is really taking the
functionality of your UI and putting it inside
Google Apps, inside Gmail Calendar docs--sorry,
in the Gmail Calendar spreadsheets and Google
sites. It's all based off a standard HTML
JavaScript, CSS, and the OpenSocial standard
for gadgets. Here's a few quick examples of
that, this is from at [INDISTINCT] GeoStudio,
it's an issue tracking application, and they
allow a project manager to have up to date
access to the issues that their software product
has right from within Google--sorry, Google
mail. It's on the left navigation, they always
have easy access to that, when they click
on that, it opens up the GeoStudio application.
Gmail Contextual Gadgets are perhaps my favorite
feature that's launched, so, I saved it for
close to the end here. Gmail Contextual Gadgets
allow you to display a gadget from your application
below an email based off the context of that
email. So, you can look at the email and you
could say this email is from a guy named Ryan
Boyd, and this first gadget here looks Ryan
Boyd up in the social networks, and finds
my picture, my Facebook profile, my LinkedIn
profile, my Twitter profile, as well as previous
messages that I have sent. And then the second
contextual gadget is a more business used
case where the email detects at the word timesheet
was present in the email, and it basically
says, "Hey Ryan, do you need to complete your
timesheet for this week?" And you can enter
that information in authenticated and authorized
way right where--from within the context on
your email, drastically improving your productivity.
Here's one last example of contextual gadgets,
and this is from a company called Aperio and
Aperio is a consulting company, and when they
receive an email from one of their customers,
they can look up that customer's project information
in their systems, in their internal systems
and their CRM application and provide that
information right there. So, in summary, you
can build applications for yourself, for your
company, or you can make a living, building
application for others, or selling applications
in the Apps Marketplace. If you want to make
a living, building application for others,
a good way to start is becoming a reseller
of Google Apps and doing integrations for
customers. You can build your applications
anywhere you want, and you can integrate with
all sorts of components of Google Apps.
Integrate
with
the UI, integrates with the data, integrate
with the accounts, and it's not all about
the Cloud, some systems are still behind the
firewall, and
you can still access those. If you want a
more lightweight scripting environment instead
of
a full application,
you can write scripts using Google Apps script.
So, we have some resources here, I have--I
will be around here for another few minutes
before I start the next session which is on
the
Apps Marketplace, and then following that,
there's a session that dives a little bit
more into OpenID and OAuth in the
various used cases. So, thank you very much,
I hope you all learned something.